okay let's play this guy there is like a
small potential a potential for him to
be magnosia magnus like this
doctor whatever nicknames
so yeah
let's check check it out
okay
c3 okay fine
i think d5 doesn't move
and then what do they
it's like bishop b4 knight c3 bishop g4
bcp2 takes on f3 takes on f3 queen c4
bishop b4 knight
i think it was a theory
yeah judging by his speed it is a theory
yeah so what do we play here queen takes
or
or not basically or b takes
b x is quite safe
but probably slightly worse queen takes
i don't know what's wrong with queen
takes
i mean he will just castle
we go 997 make sure
our king makes it to the corner and then
then we'll
play the game
and d5 so where does the queen belong
like queen a4 check is still
still there so probably go to g7
he probably wants queen g4
and then
like a normal move would be to take on
c3
and we can also try bishop d6
queen g7 like rook g8 q7 long castle
yeah why not i mean it's probably bad
but
it's sort of not bad enough to
make us do something else
should take c7 okay this guy is not
magnus i'll tell you
i'll tell you the truth
it doesn't mean i'll necessarily win it
but
magnus is a bit better i will say
okay okay have to eat maybe make sense
like in general this pawn on d5 is quite
weak
so yeah white will
sort of bring everybody to defend it and
we should normally use it to
create some
second view a second weakness as they
called
like you normally improve a little
then something starts happening in the
kingside or
or somewhere else
rookie 5 does it make sense so he wants
to play knight t4
we can even take on c3 and play rookie 2
we can also play like win e7 maybe yeah
queen 7 looks reasonable
so i'm just preventing knight e4
he goes to a4
which allows some queen a3
also lost queen b4
yeah it starts to look really bad for
white i would say okay let's try queen
before
so first of all we are threatening
rookie one check and secondly we're
threatening
b5
which would drop the knight i believe
yeah so
looks quite unpleasant
i mean to say the least to me just feels
like
white is almost lost
i mean he probably has to play queen d2
but then like even if we trade it's very
very
suspicious
like we just take rookie one play i
don't know e5
b should be fives and h4 or maybe even
h4 first
yeah let's just go for it takes
so some b5 is not yet winning for some
reason
so we give a check to make sure there is
no king of one
now we probably play like h4
or maybe b5 check first still
yeah i guess bcp 5 we have to include
it's an h4
rook c1 was also interesting chris
restricting the knight
then like white has to play knight b2 at
some point which is probably also quite
bad
yeah he plays knight c5
i thought we will
create some threads there
93 is a threat yeah i thought like age
stakes and then rookie three
but yeah roger two seems to hold yeah i
mean it looked very ugly to me
from far away
i mean i still think it's ugly but maybe
it just works
okay anyway let's just do this
yeah rookie three rook to two we we
include anyway
then we all think we still have ideas
like f5
it's not that white is completely fine
but yeah maybe it's not like dead lost
what is he thinking about
and then wow he takes but rook is three
no
no this is quite bad
no he had to play uh rogue jutto of
course and then as a point is that
basically we cannot
we cannot stop uh knight xb7 or knight
takes a6
which makes it
i mean a bit more complicated than as
unexpected yeah he offers a draw but
[Music]
yeah with an extra rook i'll probably
wait for him to resign